[Narrator:] This is the story of the United States
Public Health Service.
It's a story of many parts.
It's a story of hospitals like this one in New Orleans
and this one in Norfolk, Virginia.
It's a story of the leprosarium in Carville, Louisiana,
the hospital for study and treatment of drug
addiction in Lexington, Kentucky,
the National Institutes of Health in Bethesda,
Maryland, and the Clinical Center there.
It's the story of quarantine stations at our major
ports of entry like this one at Miami,
and this one at New Orleans.
As a matter of fact, the story of the Public Health
Service can be found in many places
throughout the United States and its territories.
[ Music ]
The story began with President John Adams in
1798, when he signed the Act
establishing the  Marine Hospital Service,
forerunner of the Public Health Service today.
Many people have helped establish the Service's
distinguished traditions,
people like Joseph Goldberger, who pioneered in
studies of pellagra,
a once widespread dietary disease.
Leslie Lumsden, whose work in typhoid
epidemiology and rural sanitation
is a cornerstone of modern public health practice.
Joseph Mountain who stimulated nationwide
interest in many fields of public health practice
and administration, such as chronic disease control
and the health problems of the aging.
Charles Armstrong whose adaptation of
poliomyelitis to rodents speeded up polio research,
and Edward Francis, whose studies of the origin
and causes of tularemia have done much
to improve our knowledge of this disease.
Other Public Health Service scientists developed
vaccines against Rocky Mountain Spotted Fever
and typhus, and perfected many others.
The Service was also instrumental in the virtual
eradication of malaria in the United States.
Today, the Public Health Service employs over
21,000 people
in about 250 occupational specialties.
These include physicians,
nurses,
sanitary engineers,
dentists,
scientists,
dieticians,
veterinarians,
physical therapists,
pharmacists,
social workers,
administrative specialists,
instrument-makers,
animal caretakers,
nursing assistants,
clerical personnel,
and a host of other specialists necessary to the
effective operation of the Service.
Civil Service personnel comprise the largest
number of these employees.
About one-fifth of the Service's employees are
regular and reserve officers of the Commissioned
Corp,
a long-established career organization of
professional medical and health personnel,
and one of the uniformed services of our country.
Because of the professional nature of the
Service's activities,
many of its major programs are directed by
commissioned officers.
Officers of the Commissioned Corp serve either in
the regular corps, or career service,
or in the reserve corps on active or inactive duty.
Officers on inactive duty belong to a component of
the reserve corps
known as the Commissioned Reserve.
The Commissioned Reserve is a readily available
personnel held in reserve for grave national
emergencies,
and trained to meet critical situations affecting the
health and well-being of large numbers of people.
Such emergencies might involve the destruction of
our cities,
extensive illness and death from disease
epidemics,
or the unusual health problems associated with
major natural disasters.
The Public Health Service is the oldest and largest
of the five operating agencies that comprise
the United States Department of Health, Education,
and Welfare.
The Public Health Service is organized to work
closely with state and national organizations
through national conferences and advisory groups
of private citizens,
to give meaning and direction to its many
programs.
The actual work of the Service is carried on by four
major bureaus.
One of these bureaus is the Office of the Surgeon
General.
This is not an operating bureau, but is responsible
for coordinating activities
and providing administrative services for the three
other bureaus.
The three other bureaus, known as operating
bureaus, are the Bureau of Medical Services,
the Bureau of State Services, and the National
Institutes of Health.
Let's examine these bureaus and their activities
one at a time.
First, the Bureau of Medical Services.
This bureau operates foreign quarantine programs.
It administers grants for construction of hospitals
and medical facilities, operates numerous hospitals
and outpatient clinics, and the Indian Health
Program.
It conducts dental and nursing studies of
personnel needs,
and makes professional personnel available upon
request to other federal agencies.
Personnel in the Bureau of Medical Services work
in Public Health Service hospitals
from Massachusetts to California, and in outpatient
clinics providing medical care to seamen
of the United States Merchant Marine, the United  States Coast Guard,
and the families of Coast Guard officers and enlisted personnel.
They serve in Public Health Service hospitals and clinics on Indian reservations in the United States and Alaska,
in federal prisons,
with the Coast Guard in Alaska,
and with the Coast Guard on the high seas.
Personnel from the Bureau of Medical Services are
also assigned to quarantine duty
with United States embassies in foreign countries.
In this country, quarantined personnel are on duty
at our major seaports,
and at our international airports, where they
determine the health status of passengers
entering the United States from abroad
and keep daily surveillance for disease-bearing
insects that may find their way into this country.
The Bureau of Medical Services is also
responsible for the Hospital Construction Program,
under which the federal government matches state
and local funds for the construction of hospitals
and other medical facilities in communities where
there are no such facilities,
or where existing facilities are inadequate.
Public Health Practice, the control of disease in the
community as a whole, is the responsibility of the
second major operating bureau, the Bureau of
State Services.
Through research, demonstration, training, and
consultation, the personnel of this bureau
work closely with state and local health agencies
on many different health problems.
The bureau coordinates the activities of regional
staffs located in eight of the
nine regional headquarters of the Department of
Health, Education, and Welfare.
It is through these regional staffs that many of the
Public Health Service's cooperative federal, state,
and interstate programs reach the people of this
country.
The Bureau of State Services assists state and
community health officials on such problems
as mosquito and fly control,
animal-borne diseases,
safety of public water supplies,
water pollution control,
standards of sanitation governing the preparation
and serving of food and milk.
Personnel of the Bureau of State Services study,
develop, and demonstrate
methods of community refuse disposal.
They train local health personnel in effective
methods of sewage treatment,
in rodent control, and in housing hygiene.
They study the relationship between air quality and
community health
and conduct research to improve the working
environment of the industrial worker.
They also work on Indian reservations to eliminate
health problems caused by insanitary conditions.
The Bureau of State Services provides grants to
states to help them finance health programs,
such as the establishment of new county and local
health services.
In addition, there are grants to states for specific
health problems.
These include tuberculosis, diabetes, heart
disease, venereal disease, cancer,
and dental decay.
Grants are also made to support studies of the
special problems of the older citizens
in our communities.
Specially trained epidemic intelligence officers of the Bureau of State Services provide disaster aid
to states in the form of prompt investigation of
disease outbreaks.
Another unit of this bureau, The National Office of
Vital Statistics, compiles, analyzes, and publishes
national reports on births, deaths, and disease
outbreaks.
To augment its field activities and the research
programs of the service,
the Bureau of State Services operates the
Communicable Disease Center in Atlanta, Georgia,
the Robert A. Taft Sanitary Engineering Center in
Cincinnati, Ohio,
and the Arctic Health Research Center in
Anchorage, Alaska.
The global scope of the bureau's activities is
indicated by its international health programs
in approximately 60 foreign countries where the
service provides technical assistance
in the development of health services.
Here are some nurses in Iran.
This is a physician in Formosa
and this is a sanitary engineer in Iraq.
The third major operating bureau in the Public
Health Service is the National Institutes of Health
in Bethesda, Maryland.
This bureau referred to for brevity as NIH, consists
of seven research institutes, a clinical center,
and four independent divisions.
Although the service conducts research programs in many places, NIH is the largest installation
for this type of work.
In modern, well-equipped laboratories, NIH
scientists are making important progress
in many areas of research.
In areas such as heart disease,
cancer,
mental illness,
arthritis and the metabolic disorders,
the neurological and sensory disorders,
allergies and infectious diseases,
and diseases of the mouth and teeth.
At the Clinical Center, the findings of the laboratory scientists and the experience of the physician
are brought together in a concentrated attack on disease to accelerate man's knowledge
of some of our most stubborn disease problems.
NIH scientists also work at the Public Health  Service's Rocky Mountain Laboratory
in Hamilton, Montana, where they study diseases that are transmissible from animals to man.
NIH has also the responsibility of certifying the  safety, purity and potency of biologics
used in the treatment of disease.
Over two-thirds of all the funds appropriated to the National Institutes of Health by the Congress
are awarded to scientists in the nation's medical schools, universities and other research centers.
These federal funds are helping to expand medical
research and research training
throughout the country.
As a result, our knowledge of the major diseases
of man is rapidly increasing, bringing us closer to
the day
when the main causes of disability and early death
can be reduced to a minimum.
One type of award granted by NIH helps medical
schools expand their training facilities,
such as laboratories and classrooms which permit
modern methods of instruction.
Another type of award is the Research Fellowship
which helps talented young scientists
enter research careers.
Still other funds are granted to non-profit
institutions for the construction
of essential research facilities in many parts of the
country.
[Music]
Now let's look once again, but briefly, at the
organization of the Public Health Service.
It is part of the United States Department of Health,
Education, and Welfare.
Under the direction of the Surgeon General, the
Service administers programs
in three major areas of activity.
These are research into the causes of disease,
the prevention of disease and promotion of health,
and the care and treatment of patients who look to
us for this kind of service.
Through its 21,000 employees, the Public Health
Service today brings benefits to every American,
not so much as a direct dispenser of services, but
as a leader and guiding influence.
The Service's work is reflected in an increasing
store of professional information,
[ Music ]
in popular knowledge of medical developments,
in improved local health programs throughout the
United States and its territories.
The Public Health Service, as it has for more than
150 years, is dedicating its energies
and resources to increasing man's knowledge of the cause, prevention, treatment, and control of disease,
that the people of this nation and their
children are more adequately protected than
than ever before from the suffering and hardships  produced by disease.
[Music